-Welcome back.
-Thank you so much.
-It is fan-- It is great
to see you in person.
-I know. Last time,
I was on Zoom with you.
-Zoomers, Zooming,
but I appreciate you
doing that for us.
-And no masks.
And now we're no masks.
The people are here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is amazing.
Hi, guys!
-You look fantastic.
-Thank you.
-I'm happy you're here.
And I asked you to play
"VR Pictionary" tonight.
-Yes.
-You were very nice,
and you said yes,
but you were very honest,
and you said,
"I just want to let you know,
I'm terrible at drawing."
-There are very few things
that give me major anxiety,
and drawing is one of --
I am terrible at drawing.
I cannot draw a stick figure.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, to prove this,
you brought a photo
that you drew.
-Okay.
Well, wait.
Let me give context.
-Before we see it -- Yeah.
-So, during COVID,
my friend group,
we were doing
all these online games together,
and a lot was Pictionary
and Charades and all this stuff.
And one of the games
was a drawing game,
and we had to make
a self-portrait,
and this one was mine.
-Okay. I-I --
You guys be the judge.
I don't know.
Is this that bad?
This is, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-So...
Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
So...
[ Both laugh ]
I had a high ponytail
that day, and I was wearing --
You were the Genie in "Aladdin"
for an off-Broadway version.
[ Laughter ]
-My assistant still
has this as my caller I.D.
[ Laughter ]
Literally!
-I'm gonna say
you have to use this.
-Oh, she uses it for everything.
-You have to post this.
-She's on the verge of getting
fired for how often she uses it.
Let me tell you.
-That's so funny.
-So that's my
drawing capabilities.
-Yeah, well, I appre--
Well, I appreciate you
doubly playing the game.
You're a good sport.
-You're welcome.
-I saw you at the Emmys
a couple weeks ago.
-Yeah.
-Looking gorgeous, as always.
-Oh, thank you so much.
-Ooh, la la.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Beautiful.
-They literally cut that dress
before I walked out.
That was a full gown.
-What?
-And they just -- we cut it.
We went wild.
-Wait. So it was
just gonna be all...
-It was all long.
No leg.
-And we cut it.
-And then you said, "All leg."
-Yeah, and then we just cut it
before I walked --
Can you imagine the insanity
of doing that
before I walked out?
-I love that you did that.
-I know! We just cut it.
-Isn't that the best to just go,
"I'm just gonna take this risk
and see what's up"?
-Yeah, you could do that
with your suit pants.
You could just cut them
before you come out.
[ Laughter ]
You never know.
-We'll get there.
We got a long -- got a long
season ahead of us.
[ Both laugh ]
Congrats. You were nominated
for your show,
"The Flight Attendant."
You're fantastic in it.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
-Thanks, guys.
-Well, Sharon Stone plays --
played your mom
in a few episodes,
and you posted this,
you and Sharon,
and I just want to say that
I was once in a movie
where Sharon Stone
played my mother...
-You know, I heard this.
-...in a flashback.
It wasn't me.
It was a kid, a little boy,
but his mom was Sharon Stone.
-It's almost like
we're TV related.
-Yeah, kind of. Right?
-TV mom.
-My mother -- my real mother
in real life,
was, like, over the moon.
She was like, "Finally!
This is the best casting ever!"
[ Laughter ]
"I am Sharon Stone!"
Yeah, yeah.
-It's so funny that you bring
your mom up because,
when I posted that --
So, I was like the first person
to announce
that Sharon was on our show.
So I posted that picture
that you just showed.
And what I wrote in my --
what I wrote was,
"Finally, the cat's
out of the bag.
@SharonStone.
Hi, Mom."
And that night, I was looking
through the comments,
and my real mom
was the top comment,
and she put, "Hi!"
[ Laughter ]
I had to text her, like,
"Mom, you can just text me."
-"We're not
having a conversation."
-Talking about Sharon.
[ Laughter ]
It was so funny.
I didn't know if she was
being geniously hilarious,
or she really was just like,
"That's me!"
-Yeah, of course.
-Yeah, I don't know.
Either way, it made me laugh.
-You can't beat moms, right?
-No.
-They're the greatest.
-The best.
-You were sitting at the Emmys
with your boyfriend, who --
a friend of our show, too.
-Yes.
-Tom Pelphrey.
-Just amazing on "Ozark."
-So good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
-Uh...
How did you two meet?
-So, we actually --
we have the same manager.
This is a very Hollywood story.
I know.
We have the same manager.
-No, I like it.
-And actually, I was just
shooting a film in Berlin.
And about six months --
even longer, nine months ago,
my manager was submitting
different clients
and had asked me
if I knew who Tom was.
And she goes,
"And side note, he's single."
This was a while ago.
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Oh, I'm not ready to date.
And I don't know
who we're casting."
And I didn't even know
who he was.
And I had told my sister,
I'm like,
"Do you know this
Tom Pelphrey?" she's like,
[ Gasps ]
"Have you seen 'Ozark'?!"
-Oh, my gosh!
-And I was like,
"No, I haven't!"
-"Have you seen 'Ozark'?!"
-No, I think I'm the only one
that hasn't seen it,
and they were like,
"How can you not see 'Ozark'?!"
-Yeah, exactly.
-People lose their mind.
-Oh, I know. I was that person
for a long time.
-It's crazy.
-I mean, on the other end.
I was with you.
-Like, psychos.
-People will freak out.
They go, "You haven't even --"
Yeah, Jason Bateman
yelled at me --
"You haven't seen 'Ozark'?!"
-I know!
[ Laughter ]
God, back off.
-Yeah, but...
-So, anyway...
The months had gone on,
and we had never met,
and I was out here
promoting "Flight Attendant"
with that same manager,
who's his manager,
and she's like, "I'm going to
the 'Ozark' premiere tonight.
Do you want to come with me?"
And it didn't even occur to me,
and I was like,
"Yeah, I'll go."
So I got all dressed up,
and I was standing there,
and I was at the bathroom,
and I was waiting.
And I hear this voice.
It was Tom, and he's like,
"Where's this Kaley?"
And I was like,
And I turned around,
and it was Tom, and it was like
[ Vocalizing ]
It was like love at first sight.
That was --
The world stopped.
-Oh, I love that.
-I know.
-I love that.
It's a great story.
-It was really sweet, yeah.
-Well, you guys looked
great together at the Emmys.
-And I still have to pee.
I never went to the bathroom.
-Never went to the bathroom.
-Yeah, had to pee
that whole night.
I want to talk about your movie.
Let's talk about "Meet Cute."
-Yeah, "Meet Cute."
-Now, "Meet Cute," in the --
I only learned about this
when I think it was on
after "Saturday Night Live,"
is a term for, in a script
when the two people,
that the romantic leads meet.
-It's like an accident,
like, a cute way to meet.
I mean, meet cu--
-Yeah.
That's what a meet cute --
Yeah, I mean I had to --
I didn't know what that was.
-I didn't, either,
and I kept saying, "This doesn't
really roll off the tongue."
And then we said it
so many times
that I was like,
"Okay, whatever. It's fine."
-The movie is a --
-It's a meet cute.
-Is exactly a meet cute.
-Yes.
-And so you're meeting
the very cute Pete Davidson.
-Yes. Yes.
-So it's you and Pete.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, no, he was great.
He actually -- meeting him
in real life was
an interesting situation.
-Have you known Pete or...?
-No.
So, he was attached
to this film way before I was.
And so when I actually attached,
obviously everyone was like,
"You guys need to meet.
We hope that there's chemistry."
Like, we had never met, ever.
So, we get in contact,
and he was in L.A.
for a few days and, like, "Okay.
Maybe we should meet
for a coffee.
Let's meet the director."
Like, I had never met him
or anything, hadn't talked
to him about the project.
So I find out
that he would like to meet me,
but he wanted to meet me
in an escape room.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like,
"You know what, Pete?
Not everyone
has to end up on TMZ."
[ Laughter ]
Like, Oh, my gosh, like...
I'm like,
"Why can't anything be normal?"
So I'm like, "Am I --"
-Pete, that's funny.
-Yeah. So we did.
Me, the director, and Pete,
I met him in an escape room.
[ Laughter ]
-That's an interesting way
to meet someone.
-You really can learn
a lot about someone
in an escape room, yeah.
-How is --
How are you, and how is Pete
in an escape room?
-I don't enjoy escape rooms.
I like answers.
I don't want to know why
there's a 6 on the ceiling
and why it connects to the bike
that opens the door.
I hate that. Like, just, like,
"Get me out of here."
-You're out of there, yeah.
-Yeah, Pete just laughs a lot.
I don't even know if he knows
what he's laughing at.
-Yeah, yeah.
He's just a happy guy.
-He's a happy guy.
-He's a happy human being.
-Very happy.
-But you do get to know
how someone
reacts under pressure.
And would you ever do
an escape room again?
-Yes. In fact, my next co-star
I'm going to bring
to that escape room
so I look like a genius
because I'm gonna get out.
I know exactly how to get out.
-That is brilliant.
-Yeah.
So, thank you, Pete.
-That's actually a good move.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kaley Cuoco
in "Meet Cute."
Take a look at this.
-Thirsty?
-Hmm?
-Uh, for a drink.
Not -- Not sexually.
Gross. I didn't --
I didn't mean it like --
I'm gonna order
an alcoholic beverage.
Would you like to have
one, too, with me?
-Uh, s-sure. W-Why not?
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
Great.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Clears throat ] Phil?
-What can I get you?
-Old Fashioned.
[ Both laugh ]
-How adorable.
There's a real cute vibe
going on here.
-Two Old Fashioneds,
and you can cut that out, Phil.
Hi. I'm Sheila.
-Hi.
I'm, uh -- I'm Gary.
-Oh, Gary.
Wow.
So we both have,
like, old-timey names.
-Yeah, I guess.
Very sadistic parents.
-Oh.
Don't even get me started.
I mean, there's
no couch in here.
[ Laughs ]
Kaley Cuoco, everybody!
"Meet Cute" premieres tomorrow
exclusively on Peacock.